[Music]  brothers and sisters I shall Adela and  her one of the beloved wives of the  Prophet peace be upon him told us that  before the ten nights arrived of the  last 10 days of Ramadan the Prophet  peace be upon him would physically  prepare himself and prepare his bill and  get himself ready to catch lailatul  color the night that is so so important  that's equivalent to 1000 months 83  years of worship and brothers and  sisters we need to do exactly the same  thing we prepare yourself physically for  a marathon for a boxing match probably  much whatever it may be this is your  spiritual preparation make sure you make  the most out of these ten nights in sha  allah and do not waste a single moment  because I'm long